I wonder so have you ever felt pain and those few
moments before what we now know his pain crawled
its way out of the dark abyss itself Yuji had just
assumed everything was sweet now Tsumiki was safe
megumi would be all right and you would follow
up after and then kill Sukuna along with Yuji
and release Gojo who would in turn take care of
Kenjaku the plan literally had no folds apart from
the fact that they don't own the playing field
they're standing on this is not their domain like
I thought everything was already messed up enough
for our main crew and we didn't need anything else
to possibly hinder them and their efforts to stop
this culling game but I literally couldn't have
been further from the truth it seems Gage Akutami
is all about letting us the viewers fall into
a spot of Despair pretty similar to how I would
imagine Yuji is feeling right now just before we
do move forward into the culmination of Sukuna's
plan and the moment he changed Jujutsu Kaisen
forever if you are new around here and want to
watch more stuff just like this then make sure
you hit that subscribe button and leave a like
down below as it really helps out with pushing my
content to a bunch of new amazing people plus I've
got some big news that I'd like to share right at
the very end of the video by the way enough of
that let's get into the return of the Demon Lord
back Atop The Roof sadly Tsumiki was then revealed
to be an imposter watching this thing in front of
him cackle Megumi asks the Imposter who they are
Twitchy hysterically gloats that she's definitely
his big sister so this person inside of Mega me is
actually called a Yoruzu a sorcerer from at least
1000 years ago just like a few of the other people
here Tsumiki who obviously just wants to know why
is told as she pretended to be his big sister
to use the three points for her own game she
hasn't had a good fight in at least a thousand
years and wants to choose her battle along with
this location claiming that she wants to take
on Sukuna first moth like wings began forming
on her back before she jumps off the building
and begins boosting away Yuji and Hannah like
instantly go to give Chase not wanting her
to escape however like everyone plays just
remember back episode 7 right here and right now
already in a moment of Despair Sukuna uses that
opportunity to appear on the side of Yuji's
face and utter the words in chain as per The
Binding vowel shown in chapter 11 or episode 7 you
hear is intently forced to hand over his body to
Sukuna without any hesitation Sukuna immediately
appears on the back of henna taking her out for
the complete ease looking over at me and me whose
brain must be going through it right now so Corner
explains that he once made a vowel of Yuji having
explained that he can't harm anyone to Mega me he
knows they're from here on out everything that he
does is just a complete gamble sending some form
of like channeling curse energy to Yuji's finger
Sukuna then proceeds to freaking tear his entire
finger off screaming at this moment and like pure
joy he explained that it was a gamble because he
wasn't even sure if Yuji included himself in the
veil when stipulating the condition that Sukuna
must not hurt anyone Megumi Megumi typical man
like instantly pulls out the arm movements to do
Mahoraga but I honestly can't blame him he doesn't
really have any other choice at the moment so as
he tries to summon Mahoraga Sukuna Datsun graving
his face and restricting the summoning seal before
shoving his finger down her boy's unsuspecting
throat with the cursed energy pulsating through
Mega me an unconscious Yoji comes to not even
realizing what just happened as per the vowel
stipulations however standing opposite his boy
he hears Sukuna say that indeed he's something
interesting in the future didn't they raising his
head we see that no one other than the king of
curses himself has supposedly fully reincarnated
inside of Megumi Fushiguro's body going back
probably for a last time I would say enter the
inner world of Sukuna's we see him monologue
about the intricacies of his plan for Megumi
back during the day when he confronted Megumi
as Yuji for the first time he sensed unmatched
Potential from him his cursed techniques and
his abilities he knew that he could have forced
Megumi to eat his finger then and there that day
but it purposefully waited until he had built
up enough strength instead of Yuji to initiate
the vowel atop the building meguna which is like
Sukuna megumi mix up I'm just gonna call him that
sometimes the absolute Beast himself stands there
leaving Yuji stun asking for his friend to just
talk to him yet as we all probably expected was
just about to happen the demon Megumi as Sukuna
comes in will they charge and punches Yuji like
and this wasn't any ordinary level of punch as
well meant to separated the fabric around the area
that he has on Yuji like it made Yuji freaking
throw up while sending him hurling through a
multitude of different skyscrapers eventually
though Yuji ends up finishing his destructive
path on a rooftop of another building completely
unconscious and covered in rubble noticing some
people approaching the area Sukuna states that in
every damn age and sex always come crawling out of
the woodwork placing his hands together it informs
the sign of megumi's tin Shadows technique more
specifically the hand signs for New Way instantly
a monolithic sized Norway is summoned out of a
nearby Skyscraper with everyone reacting in pure
shock and or the size of no way it releases
it's usually pretty ineffective attack that
simply stuns people yet this time it rains deadly
lightning down on everyone from the sky above
having recovered from a previous beating henna
quickly makes your appearance by shooting over
showing up behind the revived demon seeing her
so couldn't realizes that Hannah and the angel
co-exist and thus she can recover very fast to
say like in comparison to him and Yuji in the
past given that Hannah is extremely in love with
mega me I would say probably from what I've read
so far she screams in hesitation not wanting to
hurt Mega me however Angel insists that there is
no other choice he is the disgraced one and must
be eliminated right away thus as Hannah cries
to get mega me back Angel becomes reciting the
Incarnation to dispel evil itself speaking to God
now she tells him to purify all remove his anguish
transgressions and guilt to guide him on the
correct path instantly Jacobs later initiates fell
in the sky with some form of holy symbol before
a mess of pure light energy strikes down upon the
disgraced one himself with a mass of light bearing
down on meguna it begins tearing at Sukuna's soul
in an attempt to bring me back antenna is crying
screaming that Mega me belongs to her it appears
as if the technique has actually managed to work
dispelling Sukuna's Spirit from megumi's body but
remember like honestly hit just how I said before
the incarnated sorcerers and people like Sukuna
can mimic how their body used to behave while
Angel realizes that Sukuna is still in control and
manipulating henna with megumi's voice not paying
attention though Hanna falls into megumi's arms
saying that she's always sadly though she's unable
to continue her sentence as Sukuna fully reveals
himself before going to strike on an unsuspecting
Hanna calling her a foolish human Sukuna like
an absolutely rabid dog bites in tears at Hannah
before throwing her across the entirety of the
building causing her to smash into the side of
the protective railing Yuji down below watching
this in shock and not even able to comprehend
what just happened Witnesses Hannah thud onto the
ground below with no indication that she'll ever
return looking down from the top of the building
himself Sukuna is astonished to see Yuji somehow
alive after the previous blow with rage beginning
to fill up inside of him and after realizing that
he's lost the one thing keeping him together
and giving him meaning in life Goji breaks
and a complete flash usually jumps across the
building breaking the ground below him and causing
the entire skyscraper to collapse he Graves
to Cone his neck and screams his name before
landing a ferocious punch on the king of cursor's
face forcing him to dub back across the street
regaining his footing Sukuna wonders just just
how many world usually so strong all of a sudden
then in that freaking moment Yuji takes him off
guard throwing a massive section of the previously
collapsing building into the Demon's face sitting
him shooting back once again sprinting towards
them himself Yuji grabs a piece of rebar to beat
down onto Kona worth with him dating him behind
the king of curses Sukuna Ryomen said he should
have seen us coming after all Yuji is from back
then and what do you mean by that Sukuna right
there eh anyway having blocked yuji's strike.
Sukuna counters by disarming and kicking him in
the face while noting that Kenjaku sure is Twisted
as yuji continues to approach to Kona trying to
attack him he screams asking him why why is it
that he just can't live normally like everyone
else why can't he live a life without causing
everyone to suffer Yuji continues approaching when
all of a sudden Sukuna uses his curse technique
slash to cut Yuji across the chest replying to his
previous statement Sukuna rebutters him asking him
why so weak continuously trying to cling to life
he continues by saying that this suffering is only
natural and they are meant to live life with this
misery for a moment there Yuki forgot that there
is no reasoning with him as they are and always
will be curses do he dares to Kona to chew on
his misery and suffering instead while beginning
to March towards the Demon Lord himself passing
him off is just utterly pathetic Sukuna uses his
cursed technique to continuously cut Yuji over
and over and over and over again yet our boy is
just built different and with a rage-filled heart
he puts the pain aside and stuns Sukuna by not
slowing his Approach at all standing there and
actually confused now on like what is going on
Shekinah wonders how in the world is so tough
then out of freaking nowhere and just like during
Shibuya once again proving that the body and soul
are one megumi holts Sukuna's movement allowing
his boy to follow up and Pummel his face with
a fat right Hook elsewhere and literally just
boasting it over on a blowfish Express Uraume
n Kenjaku are seen traveling towards what I assume
to be the current beat down back in the battle and
having smacked Sukuna in the face meguna remarks
that Fushiguro is indeed stopping his curse energy
output which is allowing him to only use 10 of
his maximum output hence how Yuji has managed
to survive they blows so far Sukuna notes that
well it's probably expected when the job's only
half done but still considers it enough to easily
take out Yuji standing there meguna is completely
taken by surprise as he couldn't see to Maki
actually slowly moving towards the epicenter of
a fight wanting to know what in the world caused
Sukuna's body to switch into Megumi's Maki asks to
be brought up to date with Yuji just completely
better than Bros telling her to just kill him
as he's not gonna die either way boosting in Maki
attempts to land a fat head kick in collaboration
with Yuji however megumi's body is functioning
extremely well obviously you know from what we've
seen so far and he's comfortably able to counter
his opponent still Mahi with her immense speed is
able to break through his defenses and send him
flying smashing into some railing nearby taking
the opportunity Yuji then grabs the other side
of the railing beans in it around Sukuna before
Mikey follows up in combination and kicks him into
a building nearby seeing the unharmed demon walks
out though Maki wonders if it's impossible to
actually inflict damage with his soul Liberation
sword because Sukuna will use his reverse curse
techniques to heal himself knowing that no matter
what happens here they'll have to kill Sukuna
Maki charges insane he'll have to keep up with
his speed probably running its speeds faster
than sound right now Sukuna is surprisingly
able to keep up with the attacks of Maki and Yuji
but knows that whenever he tries to attack them
with curse energy they pull from Mega me inside
him is stronger and thus to get around Megumi,
Sukuna like the absolute big brain man he is you
his curse technique cleave spider threads on the
ground below to utterly destroy the ground
and disbalance Yuji and Maki with the ground
around them now falling to bet Sukuna is able
to easily Dart in unless he fat right Hawk yet
Maki simply spits out a tooth or two leaving him
completely impressed with how she's hardly even
worried with taking damage as Sukuna falls back a
little a mysterious Foe and randomly appears from
the side and uses a maximum output technique
called Dead Calm the resulting aftermath from
the attack not only freezes the entirety of the
area but also Maki and Yuji so this mysterious
person happen to be no one other than the coldest
woman out Sukuna's right hand woman Uraume who
apologizes for a grand entrance while saying that
she's still weakened the ice around Yuji just in
case they need him Sukuna though literally doesn't
care for him anymore and instead just compliment
to her stating that focusing her energy on Maki
was a good idea believing that everything here is
sweet now Sukuna then summons no way saying that
this body is still not so they need to prepare for
the bath immediately in that moment though our
goat though looking more Bader than Bros than
ever after this Escalade burst his way out of
the ice noticing this or maybe proposes taking
him out but Sukuna says that they should just
look at him and have a good laugh flying away
for what seems like good in yuji's eyes Sukuna
having taken the body of yuji's best friend into
Uraume laugh at his face noticing that he looks
just like the person from The Harima Province
so yes I guess that brings us up to date until the
very end of Sukuna and that one time he utterly
changed due to Kaizen Forever on a different note
though I've actually started another channel in
which I'll be taking all of the fights and most
hype moments from throughout all of these series
that I've already covered and re-releasing them
independently on my Clips channel so this will
probably be one of the last fight videos that
are like I guess a re-upload in some kind of way
because this weekend I'll be releasing the full
Arc that has this video on it as well unless I've
obviously decided to cover a battle like I've done
with one punch man and one piece in the past so go
subscribe over there to my dear Volo clubs channel
and once all the art I'm getting made is sorted
then I'll start releasing a bunch of fights and
in most hype moments throughout manga that I've
covered so far for anyone else who was confused
as to why I'm actually doing this I just want to
keep my main channel for longer format content and
having a Clips channel will hopefully allow me to
like focus on making longer format content without
freaking out over actually not having uploaded for
two weeks because these videos do take a lot to
actually get out also if anyone is interested and
wants to edit chapter reviews for me then like hit
me up over on Twitter or just like message me on
Discord or something as I'm looking to revive the
Volo Channel and do future chapter reviews weekly
but just because you know like I edit script and
do everything already for my Diavolo channel I
need someone who can actually do that over on the
Volo Channel either way I hope you all enjoyed
the video and what I've got to come in the future
thanks to all of my dope Patreon's who keep me fed
every month and obviously remember to subscribe
if you are new around here and haven't already but
for now it's been your professional degenerate
Diavolo and I'll see you all in a bit bye